what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
discussing the game changing nature of
erice quirk and why I believe that arrey
is going to play a major role in the my
hero academia story in the near future
in the past I made a video about ares
backstory and the known properties of
our quirk for those of you who don't
want manga spoilers and just want to
know the basics about Ares
however this video will focus on how
Arian her quirk could completely change
the world of MHA as the story moves
forward and that includes looking at the
latest story developments about Arry and
her quirk in fact it is my opinion that
Arry and her quirk could end up driving
much of the main plot in the chapters to
come and if you think I'm crazy for
saying that about such a minor character
hear me out you may be surprised if you
enjoyed the bouken on your content on
the channel and you want us to keep it
going please leave a like to let me know
it really does help and if you happen to
be new to nml prefer get to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications just a heads up all
of our enemy our videos are now
available in audio format as a podcast
if you'd prefer to listen to us that way
just look for anime uproar audio on
Spotify Apple podcasts or wherever you
get your podcasts or you can just click
the direct links in the description
finally as I said earlier this video
will contain manga spoilers we're
talking about the latest events in the
story everything we know so far about
Arry and her quirk so with that said
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in chapter 2 v 7 of the boku
no hero manga eyes 'var revealed to all
might that he was planning to train
arrey soon and all might offer to help
we know that up to this point arrey has
been unable to control her quirk so
while her incredible ability can be very
useful at times such as when she was
able to help Deku defeat overhaul her
quirk can also be extremely dangerous
such as when she accidentally rewound
her own father out of existence
furthermore because Aries quirk works
only on people and not on inanimate
objects it isn't easy for her to
practice using her quirk she would
basically have to practice on people and
if she practices on people there is a
big risk that she might seriously injure
or even kill the person by accident with
that said thanks to the help of NATO
Manama we learned that Aries quirk is an
accumulation type quirk
this means that area needs to accumulate
power over a certain period of time
before being able to use her quirk
effectively as a result NATO was unable
to copy and use Aries quirk himself so
he couldn't give very any practical
advice about how to learn to control it
we know that Aries quirk is considered a
mutation because it is vastly different
from the quirks possessed by both her
parents and we know that her quirk
allows her to rewind a person's body
back to a previous state this has
massive potential and it could mean
helping someone heal their injuries by
rewinding them to a state before they
were injured but as we saw it could also
mean rewinding someone right out of
existence
once Harry learns to control her quirk
it could be extremely helpful and useful
not only to the people around her but to
humanity as a whole however until she
learns to control it
Aries quirk remains extremely dangerous
for everyone around her throughout her
life the nature of her quirk made Arry
potentially dangerous to the people who
were closest to her and of course this
made her feel guilty and she felt
terrible about herself this had a
profound effect on her confidence and
her self-image although such a unique
and powerful quirk could be considered a
blessing in the long run because of all
the good things that Arry could
potentially do with that in the future
so far Aries quirk has been more of a
curse than a blessing because of her
quirk
arrey accidentally killed her father as
a result she was abandoned by her mother
and because of the unique properties of
her quirk Arry was abused and
experimented on by overhaul after such
terrible experiences at such an early
age
anyone would
be forgiven if they came to view their
quark as a negative and dangerous thing
thanks to the terrible experiments that
overhaul conducted on Airy he discovered
that Aries blood has properties that can
take away the ability of other
individuals to use their quirks when
they come into contact with Aries blood
other people's bodies are rewound to a
state before their quirk manifested and
so they suddenly become quirk lists as
was the case with me do as we know
overhaul eventually ends up using Aries
blood to create special bullets that
will take away their targets ability to
use their quirk but even though Aries
quirk is the reason why media became
quirk lists after being shot with the
quirk destroying bullet Aizawa believes
that Aries quirk could also be the very
thing that allows me do to restore his
own quirk when eyes Owoh says this it is
not just a throwaway line I think that
Aries quirk will likely become a major
plot point in the boku no hero story
it's been a while since media lost the
ability to use his quirk and medial is
such an epic character with such a great
quirk that I find it very hard to
believe that horikoshi would just keep
me do quark lists for the rest of the
series instead I firmly believe that
media will eventually regain the ability
to use his quirk and based on what we
know so far it is likely that the method
which will be used to restore his quirk
is Aries power after all it was aries
blood that took away meteos ability to
use his quirk in the first place so it
is logical to think that as soon as he
learns to control her quirk she will be
the best person to restore meteos power
but restoring meteos quirk is only the
beginning knowing what we know so far
about ares abilities once she learns to
control her quirk she could potentially
do so much more she could change the
entire world of boku no hero she could
restore all might to his physical prime
she could revert kuru giri back into a
burro she could potentially even restore
all for one
to his physical prime if all-4-one is
able to somehow manipulate her
perhaps by threatening to kill someone
if she doesn't do it but more than that
arey could single-handedly become the
solution to the quark singularity issue
which has been raised many times
throughout the course of the story and
which is sure to become an important
plot point in the future work
singularity is a concept that the
villain dr. Daruma Fujiko claims to have
come up with many years ago quark
singularity refers to the idea that as
new generations of quark users are born
the quirks that the children are born
with will become stronger and stronger
as different powerful quirks mix
together to create even more powerful
quirks the world will eventually get to
the point where quirks that a user
manifests are just too strong for him or
her to control as illogical puts it the
memory will exceed the hardware meaning
that the raw power of the quark will
exceed the capabilities of the quark
user's body according to Foucault this
has already been happening since the
fourth generation of quark users arrey
herself can of course be considered a
prime example of the quark singularity
issue the quark she manifested as a
child was a mutation that didn't
resemble the quark of her parents and it
was so powerful and so destructive that
she couldn't control it
her own father died as a result of Ares
inability to control her quark logical
believes that as more and more quirks
continued to mix together over the
coming generations this phenomenon will
become more and more common and
eventually the entire world will be
thrown into chaos but here is the ironic
thing even though Airy is herself an
example of the dangers of quark
singularity she could also turn out to
be the cure for the quark singularity
problem assuming that Ares training will
be effective and that she will learn to
control her quark arrey will be able to
actually help children who manifest
quirks that are too powerful for them to
control theoretically Airy will be able
to rewind the children's bodies to a
point where their quark had not
yet manifested until they are old enough
to actually control their quirks so if
there is ever a quirk singularity arc in
boku no hero
I predict that arey will be the star of
that arc we've certainly been getting
hints in the story that children are
being born with stronger and stronger
quirks and we've had multiple examples
of children accidentally killing people
including members of their own family
specifically because they were unable to
control their quirks examples of this
include both airy and shigaraki I really
don't think that this quirk singularity
concept would have been introduced and
repeated so frequently if horikoshi
didn't intend to make a bigger deal out
of it in the future the other important
thing that we have to remember about
Aries quirk is that its current
abilities could only be the beginning of
what her quirk will be able to
accomplish once area is able to access
its full potential
we have recently seen multiple quirks
straight-up awaken and evolve in boku no
hero and while we could say that the
evolution of one for all is a one-off
because one for all is so unique the
evolution of quirks like Sagara Keys
decay and togas transform demonstrate
that quirks can still become far more
powerful and exhibit additional
abilities well into the users adulthood
so what if Aries ability to rewind
people's bodies is just scratching the
surface of her full quirk potential
what if era can eventually learn to
rewind multiple people at once
or even large groups of people overhaul
believed that he could one day use aries
power to take away the quirks of
humanity as a whole so is it possible
for arey to one day literally alter the
physical components of the entire human
race with her quirk could she one day
decide that the world would be a better
place if quirks didn't exist after all
her own quirk has been more of a curse
than a blessing for her could airy one
day become something like a villain who
wants to use her quirk to erase all
quirks from existence as intriguing as
this sounds I doubt it but who knows
what kind of abilities Aries quirk could
unlock in the future could we
to the point at which arey learns to
rewind time itself or actually send
people back in time instead of just
rewinding their bodies there are many
intriguing possibilities with this quirk
and I personally can't wait to find out
where Aries story goes from here we do
have to remember that Aries quirk is an
accumulation type quirk so Airy does not
have unlimited power her quirk will
likely get much stronger but its power
will never be unlimited because Airy
needs to take some time to charge up her
power store it and then release it when
the time is right this means that the
amount she can store is inevitably going
to be limited even if that limit ends up
being a high one I personally believe
that Airy will remain a good guy and
that she may eventually become a star of
her own spin-off or next generation boku
no hero series MHA already has the
vigilantes spin-off and provided that
the popularity of boku no hero remains
as high as it is now it isn't out of the
question that a new spin-off with
younger characters like arey could
appear this is especially possible once
the current main cast graduates from
high school since area is so much
younger than them if horikoshi wants to
create another high school story for a
new generation in a few years he could
make a spin-off that focuses on Arry and
other younger characters starting their
journey in UA as the current main cast
focuses on being pro heroes and adulting
in general we could even have a
situation where the main story ends
there is a time skip and then airy and
her age group become the main cast with
the current main cast becoming new UA
teachers it's like boruto the next
generation but for boku no hero isn't
that exciting okay fine I know that
boruto isn't the best example to use and
a lot of people would hate that idea but
if the series is making a lot of money
and the main story winds down you better
believe that they will find some way to
keep cashing in and a next generation
could be the way to do it
now obviously I'm not saying that this
will happen for sure or that area will
definitely become the new main character
of the story but I do firm
that area is going to become an
increasingly important character
especially due to the incredible nature
of her quark with all the talk about
quark singularity with the insane
evolution and awakening of quirks in
recent arcs and with me do still being
quark lists I think that airy and her
quark rewind are going to become
critical plot elements in the near
future let me know what you guys think
do you agree with me that area will
become an increasingly important
character to the story or do you think
that she will just remain an adorable
side character also assuming that Ares
quark could keep getting stronger and
stronger in the future what other
additional powers do you think that she
might be able to unlock rewinding time
itself rewinding all of humanity let me
know down below if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more videos in
this style on this channel please leave
a like to let me know and if you happen
to be new to anime uproar please don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications don't forget that you can
now listen to our videos in podcast
format just look up anime upper audio
wherever you get your podcasts or click
the links in the description I want to
give a big thank you to all of our anime
opera patrons who support our content
and make these videos possible first up
let me thank our the one tier patrons
the ones who rise above all other clans
including ingrid ah a Lola nod of
makoto-kun the world Steelers the school
bus and Tyson quit Ino I also can't
forget our awesome pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings ell
dress very dolla beat alpha do
Anatoli Cassatt ski on hell Cruz team
Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor otaku Timothy a
vodkas Jean d'Arc and Joe Stanton if you
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our page
and exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
let
Andheri people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see us space Cowboys
[Music]